hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the fifth
meditation in addition to providing an
ontological argument for the existence
of God one of the other things that
remained a current is great to do and
that's connected to this is talked about
what he calls true and immutable natures
these are the essences of things and
they exist in our minds in some way and
they could also in a certain sense exist
outside of our minds as the essences of
the things themselves if those things
actually exist and remember at this
point in the meditations he hasn't
gotten us to the juncture where we can
effectively reintroduce the entire world
so we think about what the goal of the
meditations as a whole is and meant the
goal of this meditation 5 it's to not
just engage in hyperbolic doubt it's to
extricate himself decart from all the
doubts that he has been in he introduced
doubt and deepened it brought it to what
he thinks to be its ultimate conclusion
but he did that so that he could a
reestablish a solid found a
for knowledge and indeed even for
science so he wants to see ultimately if
he can know anything about material
things anything about substances that we
call extended substances that's going to
happen later in meditation sex but he's
setting up the groundwork for that right
now
so he tells us that he can imagine and
it's important to use that term imagine
there he says I distinctly imagined that
quantity that philosophers vulgar ly are
commonly called continuous quantity what
does this mean he says that it can be
understood as extension or length
greatness and depth right so we're
talking about the three dimensions of
things and he says which are in this
this quantity or rather in the shows to
which we attribute it so you know when
we take this book for example it has
length and width and depth
it exists in space now I've actually
done something else with it I've moved
it around I've changed what he's calling
it situation or place we can also take
physical things and let's use this book
as an example each of these pages that
composes the book is a part of the book
so he says I can number in something
many diverse parts and attribute to each
of these parts all sorts of magnitudes
grounder figures you know structures
situations and movements and finally I
can assign to each of these movements
all sorts of times so what do we have
going on here we can effectively
mathematize we can you know use quantity
to understand physical material extended
objects and then he says not only can I
do this in general but says I know not
only these things with distinction when
I consider them in general but also
as as little as I apply my attention I
conceive of an infinity of particularity
'he's touching upon numbers figures
movements and other similar things whose
truth appears with so much evidence and
accords or harmonizes so well with my
nature that once I begin to discover
them to literally uncover them a clue
for the error right it doesn't appear to
me that I learn anything new but rather
that I am reminded of what I knew
earlier or before that is to say that my
perceived things which were already in
my mind as soon as I have turned my
thought towards them so what does
Descartes talking about there this is
what we often call innate ideas ideas
that we are born with and so
interestingly the card is saying not
only do we have these general
understandings of things in an outside
world that we'd be hope exists but
within the scope of my thought if I
direct my attention properly I can find
infinity of particularities that have to
do with all of these mathematical
properties and we don't learn these we
actually remind ourselves of them we
bring them out of the storehouse or
Treasury the thesaurus in Latin of
consciousness or of a memory or whatever
it is that they're stored in and we
shine the natural light upon them and we
say AHA now I understand what they are
and now notice what else he says about
these this is very important and very
interesting these aren't pure nothings
now why would you say they are nothing
well because if they were nothing then
we couldn't actually conceive of them
they
you have some sort of reality they have
the reality that earlier in meditation 3
he distinguished as objective reality
the reality that they have his ideas not
necessarily formal reality existing out
there in the world quite yet
they might not exist outside of my
thought some of these he's willing to
say probably don't exist outside of my
thought because you could never truly
find them perfectly in the natural world
but he says they're not just made up by
me even though they're it's in my power
to think about them or not think about
them and then here is where he says they
have their true and immutable nature's
not even one so their true natures right
they display themselves with clarity and
distinction with evidence as he says em
wob immovable are immutable as a way we
could translate it another way that may
be a little bit more relatable is to say
unchangeable they have natures that
cannot be altered so this is very
important they have they're within our
thought and we can think about them or
not think about them but when we do
think about them we're stuck with them
as they are we can try to think that a
triangle has four sides that's not going
to work we can try to imagine a circle
that is squashed on one side it's no
longer a circle we can try to imagine
properties such as a circle being able
to be you know collapsed into some some
other sort of thing and you know
changing the relationship between the
radius and the circumference back and
working all right these sorts of things
you could say resist our volitional
attempts to redefine them because they
have these true and immutable nature's
which all of us would be able to access
there within all of our minds the
current here is only considering his own
thought but
presumably all of us would have exactly
the same panoply of these ideas which
have their true and immutable natures
those are their essences that is the
essence of the thing and he gives you
two examples and perhaps of what we
might consider to be a third example so
let's consider each of these in turn
triangles there may be no triangles
actually existing in the the real you
know what we call the natural world the
world of extension the world in which
you're viewing this video right now
through the eyeballs in your body or
maybe you're listening to it with the
ears right there could be possibly no
perfect triangle that exists but as soon
as we think about a triangle and we
consider its nature we realize that it
has to have angles adding up to 180
degrees
now of course somebody's probably going
to bring up what about non Euclidean
geometry that's happening later
Descartes is not considering that even
non Euclidean geometry you extend it so
that you can have triangles with less
than 180 or more than hundred ad there's
still rules governing and there would
still be true and immutable dangers they
would just be true and immutable natures
that have additional properties right
you can think of this way for squares or
pentagons or whatever whatever it is
that you want right that's why we can
have equations and mathematics
describing what the angles have to add
up to so nothing says that you actually
have to think about triangle but once
you do you're going down that triangle
road and you are going to discover those
properties he also brings up God and
this is where he comes up with the
ontological argument in meditation v and
I'm not going to go over there the whole
of X I've talked about it elsewhere but
here's the general idea when you
actually consider the idea of God as a
perfect being that is a being lacking no
perfections you realize that existence
for this being and for this being alone
is one of those
actions that it cannot lack which means
that from the idea of God you can
conclude to the reality of an actually
existing God can't do that with anything
else can't do that with triangles can't
do that with mountains and valleys as
he's going to point out but you can
according to Descartes do that with God
that would be and he brings up this this
notion of true and immutable nature's by
carrying out that line of reasoning that
is an ontological argument you discover
to the degree of human being is capable
the true and immutable nature of God he
also brings up a third thing that could
be considered an example in this case
it's not so much about quantity although
we could say a quantity of one right
it's more like a nabob on switch it's
something has a property of having
something else correlated to it so it's
a rate relational property he talks
about in this in the course of this
ontological argument a mountain cannot
exist without having next to it a valley
and if you think this through you might
say well maybe it actually has several
valleys right who is the saying oh how
wide of aliens or something like that
but a mountain if it does exist on some
sort of you know plane it has to have a
valley has to have something below that
corresponds to it you could say I'm a
valley of a mountain as wealthy I guess
but there's nothing to say that they
have to have any mountains at all and
you could well imagine a world that's
perfectly flat that has no mountains and
no valleys but once you do imagine a
mountain you do have to also imagine a
valley going along with it
I guess you could say that that's part
of the true and immutable nature of
mountains
you know that's mountain hood or
mountain essence they Kurt doesn't say
that but I think it's a potential third
example of what he's talking about here
and I do want to say he only provides a
few examples but you could extend this
technically to anything that satisfy
these criteria they're not pure nothings
they are existing
in our consciousness waiting to be
brought to light
they might not exist out of our thought
but they would still have true and
immutable natures and he is going to use
this in order to eventually get himself
the whole material world back in the
scope of our knowledge
you